bonjour vous le ministre Christian Dubé
ne veut plus être le seul qui pose des
questions aux établissements de santé
régionale
il constate qu'aucun élu ne connaît
mieux la performance du réseau de santé
d'une région que le maire ou la mer est
le maire lui il rencontre ses citoyens
tous les jours mais il s'étonne que les
gestionnaires d'établissement n'est pas
besoin de rendre des comptes au maire de
la ville dans laquelle il soigne des
gens ça se fait pourtant dans d'autres
pays comme au Danemark où les élus
municipaux sont très impliqués dans
l'administration des hôpitaux je peux
vous dire que je suis très très ouvert à
ce que la reddition de compte qu'on a
mis dans le projet de loi 15 ayant un
petit peu plus loin avec un niveau
participatif plus grand de nos élus
municipaux comme c'est encore le temps
de modifier sa réforme avant qu'elle
soit adoptée Christian Dubé réfléchit
sérieusement à inclure une nouvelle
obligation pour les patrons celle de se
rapporter plusieurs fois par année au
conseil de ville qui pourrait lui aussi
exiger de meilleurs résultats un maire
qui dit ben moi ce que j'entends c'est
que nager MF est peut-être pas ouverte
aux heures ou à devrait être ouvertes
c'est ça que mes citoyens veulent c'est
qu'elle soit ouverte le samedi les
conseils d'administration avaient pas
cette reddition de compte là aux élus à
la population
la Sûreté du Québec par exemple le fait
déjà des policiers s'assoient
régulièrement avec les élus municipaux
pour faire le bilan alors je me dis si
c'est bon pour la police d'avoir un lien
local entre les policiers et les élus
municipaux pourquoi qu'on ferait pas la
même chose en santé faites quoi ici vous
à ceux qui quittent
de vous localiser avec sa réforme voilà
une manière
utile de donner
plus d'autres acteurs importants du
réseau ce qui sont les plus proches du
citoyen ici Véronique prince
Radio-Canada à Victoriaville